someone
tagged me in a very useful rubric
on uh on twitter this is jerome
lillysworth
he said i came with a perfect system
that they should have advertised so he's
he's found a
thing from yet another university saying
when you're outside you have to be in a
mask at all times
he says i came up with a perfect system
they should have advertised you only
need to do two of the following
wear a mask be six feet away from people
be outside
two of three two of three
yep two of three and that's again i like
i love this for its simplicity right and
it
um because so much of what we're being
handled handed right now are these
simple rubrics that actually
um that don't that don't describe the
nuance that we need to have
much like i love the idea of the cards
that you can hand out to people saying
actually there's three options it's not
racist and anti-racist there's racist
anti-racist and not racist here you go
you can think on this later um but also
you know
here here you go do two of these three
things pick two
yeah i mean if you if you really want to
i suppose you can do three but um pick
two and like
specifically at the policy level wear a
mask
be six feet apart from people and six
feet of course is this somewhat
arbitrary
number but um you know be physically
distanced be outside
you don't need to do all three at the
same time you just don't
um i agree but i think
built into this is there is reason you
should not want to do all three
right in some sense the policy that
we're being delivered is like why
wouldn't you do everything you can
right and the answer is you know when
you're buying a car
you do not think well i'd like to be as
safe as possible therefore
i'm going to buy a tank right because
you understand
that actually as safe as possible comes
with all kinds of costs you don't want
to pay
yeah right like you know many gallons to
the mile right right
so we recognize hey there are costs what
i'd like to be is very safe
right i don't want to be as safe as
possible because
you know a highway wouldn't work clogged
with
you know with tanks so the answer is you
should
we are all taking on risks we are all
taking
risks and there's a sweet spot and you
know and the fact is the funny thing is
you
and i uh we took our kids uh skiing this
week
and the rubric on the slopes
is very much this when you're in line
you pull up your mask
right because you're not socially
distanced you are outside
so you're probably pretty safe just by
virtue of being outside but the point is
when you're forced into close contact
you pull up your masks and then when
you're not in close contact you don't
need it
and what benefits do you get for not
having your mask up
other times you're making vitamin d
you're
interacting like a normal human being
and therefore your social relationships
are normal and better and yeah um
so anyway yes i like that rupert quite a
bit
[Music]